TESTER.
>> Josh:h:LINEUP.
THEY HAD TO CALL UP ROOKIEE
FOR THIS GAME.
THEY WILL MOVE FORWARD THROUGH
CENTER MONTH.
>> Daryl: NOT A LOT OF OFFENSE
HIS SHOT IS BLOCKED.
MERKLEY WASAS OUT
THERE AGAINST THE -- ICING
AGAINSTT.
COMING
INAROUND BUT NOT RUDOLFS BALCER.
CENTERING.
COMING OUT TO THE LINE.
THE SHOT.
SWI
SWINGED COUTURE. GOALS.
HE'S A GOOD RETRIEVER,
AND ON THE RUSH ATTACK, THEY
WERE TRYING TO CHANGE THEEW CHAS
BEING WRITTEN AS THE STARS WILL
GO BEHIND THE NET.
THE SHOT HITS THE PIPE AFTER THE
DEFLECTION FROM ROBERTSON
DALLAS.
SEGUIN LEFT CIRCLE.
IN POISON A LITTLE BIT. SUTER,
MAYBE A SMIDGE ON THE RIGHT
PAD YEAR
IN THE AMERICAN
AND NOT AN EASY SHARKS' MISERY .
0 FOR 1 GETS HIT.
JUST OVER AEEN CAUGHT AT
THE ATTACK BLUE LINE A FEW TIMES
IN THE GAME.
THE QUIET IN THE GAME HAVE COME
OFF OFIT.
>> Daryl: SO JOSE.
THIRD PERIOD IS JUST OVER AE RI
FIVE-HOLE AS THE SHARKSTARS TRY
POUNCE ON IT ON THE RIGHT SIDE.T